Carter has noticed a few quantitative
relationships related to the success of
his football team and has modelled them
with the following functions are this is
interesting so he has this function
which he denotes with capital n is the
winning / and the input of it is the
winning percentage W and then the output
is the average number of fans per game
so he's making some type of model it
says look the number of fans per game
are going to be in some way dependent on
what your winning percentage is and I'm
assuming his model the higher the
winning percentage the more fans are
going to show up at a game now this is
AB W the input is the average daily
practice time X and the output is the
winning percentage all right that makes
sense probably once again probably some
type of a positive effect of practicing
more is going to create the winning a
higher winning percentage and this other
function number of rainy days are and
then average practice time yep well the
the more rainy days are you have well
that's going to lower your average
practice time so I guess I definitely
see how practice time P would be a
function of number of rainy days the
expression n of W of X represents which
of the following well before we even
look at the choices let's think what's
happening this is another way of
denoting we're going to take X we're
going to take X right over here and we
are going to input it into W and we're
going to get out W of X and then we're
going to input that into the function N
and we are going to get out n of W of X
so what does the function W do what does
the dup function W do right over here
well that's winning percentage as a
function of practice time so you input
practice practice time and it gives you
what somehow predicts a winning
percentage winning percentage and you
take that winning percentage and you in
put it into function n function n is is
going to output the number of fans per
game based on winning percentage so this
is number of fans
so when you take the composite function
you're actually creating a function that
starts with practice time as the input
and shows a number of fans that are
going to be dependent on your practice
time so this is interesting so we should
look for a choice that says how does the
number of fans that show up at a game
how is that dependent on practice time X
all right
the team's winning percentage is a
function of the average daily practice
time now that would be just W of X if
they said just W of X that would be
winning percentage as a function of
average daily practice time so I can I
can cross that one out the average
number of fans per game this is
interesting because that's what the
final output is going to be in terms of
the average number of fans per game that
is the output of the function n the
function n right over here the average
number of fans per game as a function of
the number of rainy days in a season
nope we're not doing that we're doing it
as a function of practice time you could
construct that in fact if you wanted to
do this that would be n as a function of
W as a function of P of R so that would
have been this choice where you input
the number of rainy days from that
you're able to figure out practice time
and then you input practice time to
figure out wind percentage and then you
input wind percentage to figure out the
number of fans in the crowd but that's
not what we're doing here we're just
starting with we're just starting with
daily practice time and getting two fans
per game so let me rule this one out and
if you found this one a little bit what
I just did a little bit confusing I
encourage you to try to set up a diagram
like I just did in the beginning of
saying oh well look we could start with
r to get use that as input get average
daily practice time and then use that as
a input into W to get winning percentage
then use that as an input into n to get
average number of fans per game but
that's not what they're describing for n
of W of X the average number of fans per
game as a function of the team's average
daily practice time yeah that's what's
going on
you have your average practice time X
being inputted into the function W so
your average practice time is
going in put it into W and it outputs
winning percentage which you then input
into N and to get the average number of
fans per game the average number of fans
per game as a function of the team's
average daily practice time so yep I
definitely like that choice let's do
another one of these this is this is
interesting
deniz studied the park near her home
where she identified several
quantitative relationships and modeled
them with the following functions so be
it inputs the height of a tree in terms
of X and it outputs the number of birds
nesting in that tree H input the average
temperature specific location and it
outputs the height of the tree at that
location and T the altitude of a
specific location and then if that's the
input and then the output is the average
temperature of that location all right
this is interesting of course according
to Denise's findings which of the
following expressions represents the
height of a tree as a function of its
altitude so we want to figure out we
want to output the height of a tree and
we want to input the altitude of a
specific location so let's think about
it if we take our altitude a specific
location R and we input it into the
function T out of that we're going to
get T of our T of me write a little bit
neater we're going to get T of R which
would represent average temperature of
that location average temp and then if
we take the average temperature that
location and input it into function H
and then we input into function H we are
going to get the height of a tree at
that location so we're going to get H of
T of R and so this is going to be height
of tree at that location height of tree
and so there you have it H of T of R you
start with our altitude at a specific
location input into function TT is going
to spit out the average temperature the
location you input that into H it's
going to get the height of the tree at
that location
so H of T of our H of T of R is
this choice right over there